hi in this module i'm going to talk
about the em algorithm for learning
bayesian networks when we have
unobserved variables our training data
so let's start with our familiar movie
writing example so here remember the
station network we have a genre
it could be drama or comedy and we have
two people jim and martha who are going
to rate produce ratings
of this movie
and denote as r1 and r2
and before when we observe all the
variables in our training data we could
just use maximum likelihood which
amounts to counting and normalizing
but this only works if we observe all
the variables
in each training example
so
data collection is expensive what
happens if we don't observe some of the
for example what happens if we don't
know the genre of the movies but we only
observe
the pairs of ratings of martha and jim
so what can we do in this case
you know intuitively it seems kind of
hopeless how can we learn a bayesian
network relating g and r
when we don't even see examples of g
but we'll show that this is actually
possible
in many cases but certainly not all
cases and that's kind of the magic of em
and unsupervised learning in general
so let's try to approach this problem
top down what are the principles that we
have well maximum likelihood was
something that served quite well so
let's try to see if we can make that
work
so
generally we have a set of variables
which are hidden called big h
and we also have some variables big e
which are observed
so in this a movie reading example we
have
g is the hidden variable the two radians
is a
observed variable and we have some
little e denoting what they're observed
to
and in this case we have remember the
set of parameters which is the
probability of g and the probability of
r given
so
the
principle of maximum marginal likelihood
says
well
just maximize the probability of the
data
tweak the parameters to make that
probability as high as possible so what
this means for us is that we're going to
try to find the theta that maximizes the
probability over all
the observed
observations that we have in the
training data of the probability of that
observation given theta
so this looks very much like maximum
likelihood with the exception that we
are marginalizing out the kind of
variables
and
just to spell this out what this
quantity really is
is the summation over possible values of
the hidden variables of h equals h and e
okay so this is the principle that we
want to adhere to
so it turns out that the em algorithm is
one way of trying to optimize of this
objective
but we're gonna try to motivate em in a
more intuitive way um so em you should
think about it as a generalization of
the k-means algorithm
and remember mk means for clustering we
also had a similar problem where we have
cluster centroids and cluster
assignments both of which we didn't know
in our case the cluster centroids are
going to be generalized to parameters of
evasion network in general and the
cluster assignments are going to be
generalized to the hidden variables
so
here are the the variables we have e
h
and here is the expectation maximization
algorithm or otherwise known as m
so we're first going to initialize the
parameters randomly
and then we're going to repeat until
convergence
um it's going to alternate between two
steps the e-step and the m-step
in the e-step
what we're going to first do is
try to use the parameters to guess
the hidden variables so we're going to
compute
q of h
there's going to be a distribution over
possible values that the hidden
variables could take on and this is
going to be equal to simply the
probability of the hidden variable
condition on
the evidence or the observations that we
saw
and again this is depends on the
parameters
at the current
iteration
we're going to do this for every
possible
value of h
how do we do this
well we've already seen
how we can compute these type of
quantities given a fixed bayesian
network and this is called probabilistic
inference
so in case h is small we can just do it
kind of through force
if h is hmm we can use
if the major network is hmm we can use
forward backward in general we can use
skip sampling etc
so now what do we have
we have
these weights for every
h
and now we can create fully observed
examples now we can just pair
a particular h with our observations and
put a weight
next to that
example an important thing is now now we
have a set of weighted examples which
are fully observed
and what do we know how do we deal with
fully observed examples well we can do
maximum likelihood now
uh so we take these weight examples and
then we just count and normalize and
that gives us a fresh set of parameters
which we then can go back and repeat um
the e step and m step over and over
again
so the em algorithm is uh guaranteed to
converge to a local optimum just like k
means but it can get stuck in local
optimum and not actually solve
the global optimization problem
so let's do an example we're just going
to do one iteration of em on our
sample bayesian network
so suppose our training data includes
two examples
of r2 uh r1 and r2 equals two and two
and a second example where it's one and
two and the genre is unobserved
okay so suppose we have parameters
um that look like this so
um probability of g is just uniform
and uh probability of r given g
is uh this taken by this table
okay so now we're going to do the e step
so remember the e step is trying to
guess what g is
given each of these examples because we
don't know what
so let's look at 2 2
okay so the first example
well g could be either c or d
so there's two possibilities and for
each one i'm going to compute the
probability of the joint assignment for
now so
here i'm just going to by definition of
the bayesian network
this is going to be
um
probability of g equals c that's 0.5
times probability of
g
r equals 2 given
c g
g equals c that's 0.6
and then
r 2 equals 2 given g
that's 0.6 that gives me 0.18
and now we look at the other
possibility which is g equals d
and the probability of
g equals d
is 0.5
and the probability of r one equals two
given g equals d
that is um
a point four here
uh
point four down here
and a probability of r two equals two
given g d that's also another point four
okay so now i have uh
these uh probabilities next to
each of these possible um
extensions of this assignment
now i can normalize and that's how i get
my
q distribution
so if i normalize distribution i'm going
to get 0.69 and point
so there's more
probability uh mass on
g equals c and if i were to guess then g
equals d
okay so now i move on to the second data
point um and i'm going to do the same
thing so 1 2 could either be c
or
and i'm going to
compute the probability of each
possible
assignment to g
so i have a probability of g equals c
that's 0.5 times probability of
r 1 equals 1 given g plus c that's 0.4
and i have what is the probability of r
2 equals 2 given g equals c that's 0.6
and analogously i can compute the same
quantity for a g equals d
and again i
normalize and i get 0.5 and 0.5
okay so at this point at the end of the
e-step what i have
are four
flex style data points i started with
two data points but it's kind of been
expanded into the possible continuations
of
g
and each data point is
weighted by some
probability q of g
which is essentially how much i think
that
data point is valid in some sense
okay so now we move on to the m-step
and the m-step is just going to take
these four
data points
and
count them up and normalize
so this should be very familiar so first
we're going to estimate the probability
of g
so g can take on
uh two values c and d so i count them up
so where are the how many times did uh g
equals c occur
what shows up in the first and the third
data points
and i'm just going to add the weights
together which is 0.69
and 0.5
and what about d
well g equals d shows up in the second
and the fourth rows and that's 0.31 plus
0.5
and then i'm just going to
normalize this into an actual
distribution
so now i move on to uh the probability
of our given g
so for each possible configuration here
i'm going to count
so c1 shows up
um
here
once and that has a weight of five
um c what about c2
c2 shows up three times
one here
uh one with r2 and one down here if i
add the weights of those
i'm going to get 0.5 plus 0.69 plus 0.69
remember notice that this
example is used twice
because um
i'm generating 2 twice from c
okay so now i have these counts i
normalize this
distribution to get a distribution of r
given
g equals c so now i move on to what
happens when
g is d
so i look at d1 e1 shows up
once here with weight 0.5
and what about d equals two well that
shows up three times
um
twice here
two point three ones and then once here
i have another point five
i'm gonna add uh normalize and i get a
distribution
so the only difference between maximum
likelihood and
the m step is that now i'm adding these
fractional counts rather than
integer accounts but otherwise the logic
and the code is exactly
the same
so what have we done stepping back a
little bit intuitively we've gone from a
preliminary set of um
parameters
and i'm guessing what g is and then
using that guess of g to further refine
my estimate of the parameters and you'll
see that
the parameters
over here were 0.4 and 0.6 and now
they've been pushed
to 0.2 and 0.8
so in general em is going to
uh it tends to kind of polarize the
probabilities because that's
the best way to maximize the likelihood
of the data
and now this is just one iteration of em
now i would take these parameters and go
through the same process and go through
the same process until i
convert
okay so now let's turn to
an interesting application of of em and
that's decipherment
so this is an example of a ciphers it's
called a copial cipher which is 105 page
encrypted volume dating back from the
1730s it looks like this
so for a long time no one knew what was
what these words were
it was finally
draft in 2011 with the help of em by
kevin knight and nlp researcher
so the copious cipher is actually very
complex so what we're going to do is
motivate
the idea of using page networks for
decipherment with a simple substitution
cipher
so the idea behind the substitution
cipher is that
suppose you wanted to send an encrypted
message to someone so you're going to
generate
a substitution table which specifies how
each letter
gets transformed into another letter
cipher is going to be a permutation of
all the ones
and then you have a message you want to
send suppose you want to say hello world
um you're going to use this substitution
taper table apply it to this plain text
to produce a cipher text
and this is done by taking a mapping h
to n
um e to m
l to y
and l to y and o to t and so on
so now you hide the substitution taper
table and then you hand someone the
ciphertext or you put in a book and
period for someone to discover later
so now the question
is when someone receives a ciphertext
is given the ciphertext can they recover
the plaintext
importantly the plaintext is obviously
unknown but also the substitution table
is also unknown
this is a very challenging problem
but let's see how we can use
asian networks in particular hmm to try
to address this
so remember the process of using html
you have to think about what is the
generative story of how this data arose
so i'm going to model this as follows
i'm going to have a sequence of letters
which are plain text
and these are hidden
and we have a corresponding sequence of
characters in the
and i'm going to define
a joint distribution over all these by
first generating
the
the plain text
letters
according to a markov
model
there by a start and a bunch of
transitions
and then for each
plain text letter i'm going to generate
a ciphertext letter via some emission
so the parameters of hmm remember are
the probability of start the probability
of transition and the probability of
ignition
okay so intuitively
the transitions are going to capture
kind of the cohesion of plaintext
because it's actually
supposed to be readable and has
structures not random letters
and
the mission is going to distribution is
going to capture the substitution table
so how are we going to uh
um estimate this hmm okay
so
first of all we're going to make some
just uh simplifying choices here but
we'll show that it's kind of sufficient
so we're going to set a p-stock to
uniform
you could be a little bit more clever
but let's
i'm just going to leave it alone just
for simplicity
then the transition probabilities
so these are uh this specimen is a
biogram model over characters
and this is uh this model tells you what
looks like english or not
and the really cool thing about this is
that if we know that plain text is
supposed to be english
we can just go and grab a ton of english
and estimate
a
distribution over that text and that
gives us ptrans we don't even look at
the ciphertext
and then finally the key
uh part is that the emission
distribution
is the substitution table and that's
what we're going to estimate from em
so notice that p emission is actually
more general than a substitution it says
for every
plaintext character i can actually
generate a distribution
over
ciphertext letters whereas the
substitution table says there's exactly
one and this is more out of convenience
because it makes optimization easier
but in principle you can also think
about pmit as being constrained to just
a one-to-one mapping
okay so why do we think that this will
work intuitively
well so
the transition distributions which we've
already estimated on english it's going
to favor plain text that look like
england
while the emission distribution is going
to try to favor consistent character
substitutions so we don't want it to be
the case that a
maps to a t here and a v here and a f
there we want some consistency and by
having this emission distribution and
maximizing likelihood it's going to try
to encourage that kind of consistency so
we have these two forces kind of at play
each other with each other while we're
trying to estimate both the hidden
variables and the parameters
okay so um
let's try to
actually step into the em algorithm and
say what kind of computations are needed
to estimate this hmm
so in the e-step
what i need to do is to compute
the distribution over the hidden
variables condition
on
the observations
and to do that we introduced the forward
backward algorithm a while back
and the forward-backward algorithm is of
computing these smoothing queries which
is exactly what's the probability of
a plaintext letter being a particular
value h
given
the ciphertext that we
observe
and i'm going to
uh do this for each position
in this in this text in the cipher text
and every potential character so i'm
going to define q i of h
to be
this um probability
so this is my best guess at a particular
location what what do i think the the
plaintext character is
so now given these guesses the m-step
is going to re-estimate the substitution
table or the emission distribution so
i'm going to count a fractional
count and normalize for all the
characters
e and h
okay so
for every possible
plain text
letter and every ciphertext letter i'm
going to
look at all the positions where
the ciphertext was actually e
and i'm going to
add this probability or weight ui
of h
okay so this is going to tell me
how many times in expectation we believe
that a particular plain text
a letter and a particular ciphertext
letter are
together
and now i'm just going to normalize this
distribution so p emit of a ciphertext
letter given a plaintext letter is
proportional to
this count emit
of h and e
okay so that's it and we just run the em
algorithm and we hope for the best okay
so just to make this a little bit more
exciting
i'm going to try to code this up in
python so we can see an action
all right so a few things first so here
is our ciphertext
uh you shouldn't be able to read this
and we're going to try to decipher this
and we also have this
lm.train which is this uh quote-unquote
large amount of
um
english text
uh that we can draw from
okay so um i'm going to
we also have this utility file which
i'll just review so it allows you to
read text
we're going to convert text into a
sequence of integers just for um
simplicity
and
we also importantly have implemented
this forward backward algorithm which is
going to take a sequence of observations
and the parameters of hmm and it's going
to return q
which is a two-dimensional array uh
where it's q i for each position we have
a distribution over
possible
values of h i
okay
so
let's
decipher
the cipher song
some cipher text okay so import detail
so i'm going to
declare k to be the number of
characters so this is a lowercase
letters
uh plus space um but normalize the text
um
the first thing i want to do is
initialize the hmm
so remember the parameters of hmm i have
start
probabilities
so this is going to be p start of h
and i'm just going to set this to the
uniform distribution and all the data so
star probs
equals 1 divided by k
or
h and range
k
so that's going to be just the uniform
distribution
okay so now what about the transition
probabilities so transition probably
goes from h1 to h2 um and this is p
trans of h2 given h1 so note the order
is switched here because i want
transition problems of each one to be
actually an array which specifies the
distribution over 2.
so here we're going to
estimate this
from plain text
so i'm going to have raw text this is
i'm going to read it from lm.train
which we saw earlier
and i'm going to convert it into an
integer sequence okay
so let's see what that looks like so
that's just a sequence of integers
um
okay so now i'm going to estimate
p trans from this raw text
so this is actually going to be just a
standard
fully observable estimation problem
um so i'm going to
look over all
um
positions
starting from one to the end
and then i'm going to define
look at h1 and h2 to be consecutive or
consecutive
characters in this block character
sequence
and then i'm going to increment
a counter so i'm going to define
transition
counts
to be
for each h1 and range
k
and then for
each h2 in range k
i'm going to have a zero
okay so this is going to be a k by k 0
matrix
and then i'm going to just increment
this count
solve this account once
and then i'm going to normalize so the
way i'm going to normalize is i'm going
to define transition probabilities to be
for each h1
i'm going to
call
normalize on transition
counts out of h1
okay so for every h1
this gives me a distribution over h2
uh if i normalize it that's going to be
my transition probability
i'm done with transition probabilities
so what about emission
probabilities
um so here i have
for every h i have a distribution over
e
so this is going to be just write it out
in our mathematical language this is
going to be uh e given h
okay so here i just want to initialize
it to
the uniform distribution
so just to document this a little bit
more so we have the uniform distribution
this is done
estimate this from play text
um and this is
you know we're going to estimate this
this is just an initialization
okay so i'm going to initialize this to
for each h and
the domain of h
for each
e in
the similar domain i'm just going to
have a one over k
okay so this is a uniform distribution
of
and now
i'm going to run em
to estimate only this uh emission
problem
okay so let's
larger
so to run em i'm gonna load my
ciphertext in so observations equals
uh read the text
ciphertext and then i'm going to convert
this into an integer sequence
okay so now i'm going to iterate a
number of times let's just call it 200.
um
and then i'm going to do
the e-step
and the m-step
okay
so what happens in the e-step
i'm going to use my current setting of
parameters to guess
at what
the plaintext is
so i'm going to run
forward backward
on the observations and passing the
parameters of
the hmm
larger
okay and this is going to return q
just to know that q of h equals
i'm in mathematical notation
this is the probability
at uh
that h i equals h
um given the evidence
which is observations here
pronoun best guess so far so let's see
how we're doing we're going to do this
at each iteration
um so to do this
so for every
um let's define n equals the length of
the number of observations here so for
each
position
i'm going to look at qi so this gives me
a distribution over h
and i'm going to take the one that has
the highest probability
so then i'm going to convert this to
string
and print it out
okay
and now that finally the m step
is we're just going to count and
normalize here
so i'm going to define
a new temporary variable which is
emission counts
and this is going to be
let me just actually
cheat a little bit and i'm going to call
emission counts to be
zero
for
um
the same dimensionality as emission
props this is a matrix of zeros
okay so now we're going to up
go through um each position here
iron range
of n
and for each position
what are the possible values it can take
so
that's going to be h and i'm going to
update the emission counts
of um so emission remember is h e so h
and e is going to be observations of i
plus equal to
q
i
h
so this is probably the most uh
important line here
um
so remember q i h is what is
the weight
on
um
a particular
h at position i
and then
um emission counts is going to be h of
that particular observation and i want
to just update account
okay so now all we need to do is
normalize so emission
probabilities is for each
um
possible value of h
i'm going to
normalize
emission counts
of
h
okay so that's it
so just to uh review this briefly
so i first initialized the hmm the
starting probabilities are just uniform
and then i'm going to
estimate the transition probabilities in
a fully supervised way from plain text
where i just simply count and
normalize
and then i'm going to initialize the
emission probabilities to just uniform
for now
then i'm going to
run the em algorithm to actually
update
these emission probabilities
okay so i read in the observations
and then i'm going to iterate between
the e-step
and the m-step where in the e-step i run
forward backward to compute the
distribution over particular
uh possible values of h at each position
and print out my best guess and then i'm
going to count and normalize
all right so let's see how this uh does
so the e cipher
y
so at each pep it's going to print out
its best guess
and over time you can see that this
jumble of letters is going to slowly
evolve as em is trying to figure out
both the plaintext
as well as the substitution table
so this isn't going to be perfect
because we've used a fairly simple model
and we don't have too much data but you
can see some structure emerging so so i
both my woke alone without so that's a
real word i need one that i could
really
and so on um and plain
um there's probably something
um and so on
okay
so just for comparison this is actually
a plain text
so this is a little passage
from the little prince so i live my life
alone without anyone that i could really
talk to
until i had
an accident with my plan so definitely
far from perfect but given that we just
did it in 10 minutes it's uh maybe not
bad
okay so let me summarize we've presented
the em algorithm for estimating the
parameters of a bayesian network when
there are unobserved variables
so the overarching principle is that of
maximum marginal likelihood we're going
to find the parameters such that that
drives up the probability of the
variables that we did observe as much as
possible
so the em algorithm is going to
optimize
the
marginal likelihood objective
but fundamentally it's a chicken index
problem just like in k-mean
right we don't know the hidden variables
and we also don't know the parameters
so what we're going to do is to iterate
between
one and other so in the e-step we're
going to perform probabilistic inference
given a fixed set of parameters to
produce my our best guess over what some
of the hidden variables are and then in
the m step we're going to use these
of these probabilities as weights of
examples and then we're just going to
count and normalize two parameters and
then we go
estimate the hidden variables and
estimate the parameters and so on and so
forth
so finally once you've learned your
bayesian network you can go off and
perform inference and answer all sorts
of questions which could involve asking
about these on observed variables that
you didn't see on new test examples or
it could be used to ask questions about
observed variables
given some other variables and in
general this highlights kind of the
flexibility of bayesian networks just
because you had a certain pattern of
missingness at training time doesn't
mean you have to commit to that at test
time
so there's many applications of bayesian
networks included involving the em
algorithm we looked at the cypherment
where the goal is to infer the plaintext
from the ciphertext
em could also be used to reconstruct
phylogenetic trees given the dna of
modern organisms
and it can also be used to infer
the unknown
label of a data point where the
observations are the possible noisy
labels provided by crowd workers
so finally em is the most canonical
version of broader class of techniques
called variational inference which
actually includes things like
variational autoencoders which some of
you might have heard of
um in that case
the queue
is actually the encoder and it's given
by a neural network and the decoder is
the bayesian network
so there's a lot more to connections to
be explored and i encourage you to read
up on this by yourself